jussie Smollett gets off the hook for an
awful race hoax Mitch McConnell plays
aoc like a fish and a mosque leader in
New Zealand blames the Jews i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
sometimes the news cycle just gives you
too much to play with
I mean honestly sometimes the news cycle
is just so full of wonderful goodness
you don't know where to begin but I know
where to begin
in 2008 the US national debt was 10
trillion dollars by the end of 2018 the
debt was over 21 trillion dollars it is
rising like a hockey stick so if you
don't think we are sitting on a house of
cars you are living with your head in
the sand but since you're listening to
this podcast you are clearly smarter
than the average bear so what is your
plan can you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% you can hedge
against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with some
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty and my savings plan
is diversified yours should be - the
company I trust with precious metal
purchases Birch gold group right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move that IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA backed by physical gold and
silver which could be good for people
who want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from future
geopolitical uncertainty look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold tends to
safeguard savings with the economy
slowing down you want to be diversified
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied satisfied customers countless
five-star reviews and eight plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group get a free information
kit on physical precious metals see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you that comprehensive 16-page
kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to www.hsn
that is birchgold.com /ban go check them
out the people I trust birchgold.com
/ Ben alright so quick announcement
right off the bat we were the number one
sold book on Amazon in the last week
which is a great accomplishment I want
to thank everybody who purchased a copy
of my book the right side of history
we'll find out where it stacks on the
bestseller lists a little bit later
today suffice it to say we've sold
legitimately tens and tens and tens of
thousands of copies in the first week
alone and we couldn't have done that
without you I think it's an important
book please recommend it to your friends
and thank you so much for helping it
really sore on the bestseller charts
okay now to the news
Jessie SMO
you remember Jesse Smollett the guy from
Empire now I know maybe you've never
seen an empire maybe this wasn't one of
your shows but Jesse Samoa is apparently
an actor and he's apparently a star of
Empire a guy who thinks he's very
important so important and so upset
about Trump's America that he allegedly
sends himself in the mail a piece of
hate mail a piece of hate mail that
contained white powder and a scrawled
kranj drawing that threatened him with
death allegedly it was a letter from him
to him so there was that then he decided
you know what I didn't get enough
attention for the fake hate crime that I
tried to perpetrate via the federal
mails so I'm gonna do this thing in real
life you know take it from script to
scream now take it from page to reality
and so he found the two best white
actors he knew nigerian-born brothers or
his personal trainers and then he paid
them with a personal check to fake a
hate crime in Chicago I'm saying this
I'm gonna say allegedly just for
purposes of legal protection but it's
not some allegedly guys I mean like the
CPD had all the evidence that this
happened including the sign check so he
hears his story his story was as you'll
recall that it was two o'clock in the in
the morning in the middle of a polar
vortex in Chicago and he went to a
subway shop to get a Subway sandwich at
2:00 in the morning in a polar vortex
and there on the streets of Chicago
which voted 86% for Hillary Clinton he
was confronted by two redheaded mega
fans who spotted him and knew him from
the show Empire because if there is one
show that is deeply popular among Trump
fans it is the show Empire I mean
everywhere I go I talked with Trump fans
first thing they asked is did you see
last night's episode of Empire it's like
the number one thing they talk about I
don't know it's kind of crazy that's
just been my experience in any case this
guy walking down the street and to Magda
had it guys apparently spot him out of
the corner of their white eyes and they
look at him and they say AHA justice
Millette that guy doesn't like Trump and
this right here is mega country in the
middle of Chicago at 2:00 a.m. in a
polar vortex and so they happen to have
good news for them they happen to also
have some clothes line and bleach on
them they proceeded to wrap the
clothesline around his neck in a noose
and then they proceeded
on him and then they proceeded to kick
him in the ribs and all of this now the
best news for Jesse smart like that was
bad right but the best news for Jesse
smart he never lost his grip on that
Subway sandwich some of us have
priorities some of our priorities
include making sure that our children
are fed making sure that we have a home
making sure that we get paid for a job
well done others of us have real
priorities like you hold on to that damn
Subway sandwich when two guys are
beating the crap out of you while
committing a fake hate crime I mean that
subway sandwich huh it's a long day's
work you need a snack after you have two
guys beat you up for the press
so then Jesse smart goes back to his
apartment walks right past the the right
past the security guard outside heads on
up to his room
security guards gotta be like um Jesse
you're covered in bleach and you have a
noose around your neck what happened
apparently not apparently Jesse just
strolls right up back to his apartment
he then spends 40 minutes eating that
subway sandwich I mean shower down buddy
and then he calls the cops they show up
and he still got the noose around his
neck that's what I would do I mean I
know about you but for me if somebody
tried to hang me what I would do is just
leave that noose around my neck as long
as I could because that's just I don't
know kind of comfortable it's got a look
to it you know so the police show up and
they say Jesse will you hand over your
phone cuz you said that you were on the
phone with your manager so we can
confirm that that's true by location we
can look at your phone log and Jesse
smokes like no not gonna do that
you know why invasion of privacy guys
invasion of privacy and then he turns
over a redacted call log well the police
are able to use his cell phone number to
track down all of the calls he made that
night and all of the numbers that he
rejected and apparently the numbers he
reads acted included the numbers of the
Nigerian born brothers who it turns out
were not white
Magda hadded Donald Trump fans they were
nigerian-born personal trainers who were
friends with Jesse Smollett and who
Jesse Smollett then proceeded to throw
under the bus his new claim Jesse small
it's a new claim is that these two guys
committed a hate crime his friends
committed a hate crime against him for
no reason just for the hell of it and so
all of this came out it was obviously
stupid
it was obviously terrible the media had
jumped on it Kamala Harris called it a
modern day lynching Corey spartacus Mick
Booker said the same thing Joe by pretty
much every Democrat came out of the
woodwork
this is America this right here this is
what America looks like it looks like a
black man walking in Chicago in the
middle of a polar vortex holding onto a
Subway sandwich for dear life and being
accosted by Mike Pence and Jared Kushner
on the streets of Chicago that's America
Trump's America turns out all of it was
crap the Chicago PD tracked all of it
down they looked at legitimately
thousands of hours of footage they spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars
hundreds of man-hours they had a bunch
of police on this thing and finally they
said you know what we should probably
indict justice Millette for faking a
hate crime and making a false police
report so sixteen felony counts seems
about right to us of lying to police and
then it got to the Cook County State's
Attorney's office now in charge of the
state's counties public Attorney's
Office the state's attorney's office is
a woman named Kim Fox Kim Fox happens to
be very very close with the Obamas very
close with the Obamas and you know who
else was very close with the Obamas was
Jesse Smollett so one of Michelle
Obama's aides Tina Chen who was friends
with the Smollett family texted Kim Fox
and said you know Kim is that way you
could go see your way clear to kind of
letting this thing go could you kind of
see your way clear to letting this thing
go because you know Jesse's a nice guy
and his family knows Michelle owes
family and everybody sort of knows each
other mean there are pictures of justice
Millette with Barack and Michelle Obama
Sochi the trend called up Kim Fox and
there are pictures of Kim Fox with
Camilla Harris I mean she's a Democratic
politician she tweeted out not all that
long ago I mean just back in January I
quote I'm so excited that Kamala Harris
has decided to run for president I would
not be where I am today without her
guidance during my first run for
political office and she has continued
to mentor me as I work to reform the
criminal justice system in Cook County
well she definitely has a way of
reforming the criminal justice system in
Cook County and that is to let Jessie
Smollett off the hook because the report
today is that Kim Fox and her state's
attorney's office as of yesterday
dropped all charges against Jesse smut
they did not require him to apologize
they did not require him to do any jail
time they did not require him to do any
further community service they simply
seized his ten thousand dollar bond
which is a weird thing to do if he was
completely innocent right he says he's
innocent still well know if you're
innocent then you want your money back
but
dropped all of the charges and this was
obviously I mean there's no way this was
not done as it corrupts a political
favor to the Obama crew that's all this
was this all this was now Kim Fox as I
say it she's got an interesting history
she won office in 2016
she unseated the former Cook County
State's Attorney Anita Alvarez she lost
popularity Alvarez did over her handling
of the now infamous laQuan McDonald
murder you'll remember laQuan McDonald
was a black man shot 16 times by a
Chicago police officer named Jason van
Dyke and the entire video was kept under
wraps for like a year after the shooting
and then finally it came out and then
the officer was prosecuted she's really
entrenched in Chicago's political
machine there's a very good article
about all of this by Emily zanotti over
at Daily wire today she is very
entrenched in Chicago's political
machine she grew up in the city she went
to law school at Southern Illinois
University and then she served as an
assistant state's attorney for more than
a decade before she entered politics in
the early 2010's she served as the chief
of staff for Cook County Board President
and current mayoral candidate Tony prec
Winkle herself heavily entrenched in
Chicago politics she's taken a lot of
money from progressive organizations
including 300 thousand dollars in
donations from George Soros her office
had recent issues with handling violent
offenders she is notorious for lacks
prosecution it has really ticked off the
police who feel like she's undercut them
repeatedly there's a pending complaint
against her from the Chicago PD for
trying to interfere into their
investigation last week Chicago's
primary police union the Fraternal Order
of Police delivered a letter to the US
the US Attorney's Office in Chicago
that's the feds alleging that Fox had
tried to compromise their investigation
of Jesse Smollett at the behest of a
smollett relative and a woman by the
name of Tina Chen who we've mentioned in
a series of text messages and emails
Chen contacted Fox on behalf of
smollett's family whom she said had
concerns about the police investigation
Fox then appears to have told Chen and
subsequently the smollett relative she
would speak to police superintendent
Eddie Johnson and convinced him to turn
over investigation of the alleged hate
crime to the FBI and then all of this
came out thanks to a FOIA request and
here is what it said here's the letter
originally from Tina Chen - Kim Fox hi
Kim I sent an email to your work address
I think as well I wanted to give you a
call on behalf of Jesse's moet
and family who I know they have concerns
about the investigation I am on an 8:00
a.m. flight to New York City but please
call me before then I land about 10:15
Chicago time my cell number is bleep
many thanks and then they started
texting each other hello Kim are you
available to chat Tina Chen gave me your
number
hi are you available in five minutes I'm
at a conference in DC and will step out
yes I am spoke to the superintendent
earlier he made the ask trying to figure
out logistics I'll keep you posted
so the Chicago PD are rightly livid
about this whole thing in a second we'll
show you
Jesse smollett continuing to lie and
then we'll show you Rahm Emanuel
erupting erupting on the State
Attorney's Office
Kim Foxx there there will be an
investigation into Kim Foxx and well
there should be this is insane
in sane as we say in the membrane we'll
get to all that in one second first five
things business owners can count on from
LegalZoom number one reliability over
two million people have used Legal Zoom
to start their businesses LLC's escorts
nonprofits DBAs and more you can use
Legal Zoom to get started the right way
number two experience they've been
helping all types of business owners for
over 17 years you can count on Legal
Zoom to help with all the details
number three helpful support they have
the right people standing by ready for
your questions all based in the United
States number for legal advice Legal
Zoom is not a law firm they have a
network of independent attorneys
licensed in all 50 states which means
they can review contracts help with
employment laws advise you on a lot of
the hurdles that pop up when you are
running a business and finally number
five no surprises LegalZoom provides
complete transparency with upfront
pricing customer reviews and a
satisfaction guarantee check out Legal
Zoom today see how they can make life
better for you and your business and
don't forget to enter been at checkout
to save even more Legal Zoom is where
life meets legal I've been using Legal
Zoom for years I'm a lawyer myself and
there's nothing quite like being able to
access useful legal documents now you
can even access their network of
independent attorneys licensed in all 50
states go check them out right now Legal
Zoom calm and don't forget to enter Ben
at checkout to save even more okay so
Jesse Smollett continues to live the
state's attorney's office didn't even
leverage an apology out of jussie
Smollett over all of this here is Jesse
smart continuing to lie and invoking his
dear mother
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one
I would not be my mother's son if I was
capable of one drop of what I was been
accused of this has been an incredibly
difficult time honestly one of the worst
of my entire life but I'm a man of faith
and I'm a man that has knowledge of my
history and I would not bring my family
our lives or the movement through a fire
like this I just win it now I'd like
nothing more than to just get back to
work and move on with my life but make
no mistakes I will always continue to
fight for the justice equality and
betterment of marginalized people
everywhere well fortunately Hollywood is
a very forgiving place so you can lie
and completely fake a hate crime and
your brothers in Hollywood will simply
welcome you back your brothers and
sisters in Hollywood Hollywood is a
wonderful place the Empire writers room
sent out a tweet with a winky face
see y'all wednesday hashtag empires
hashtag Empire Fox because nothing says
that you respect your viewers quite like
backing an obvious race hoaxer
well Rahm Emanuel went on the warpath
over this so Rahm Emanuel you know that
something deeply corrupt happen when
Rahm Emmanuel and I are on the same side
this has never happened before in
presumably all of human history I am on
the same side as Rahm Emmanuel and David
Axelrod and Eddie Johnson the CPD
superintendent everybody is looking at
this and going what in the living hell
just happened here here is Rahm Emanuel
blasting the living daylights out of the
state attorney Tim Fox in the end of the
day it's mr. small at the committed this
false claim upon two individuals and who
also testified but also on this city one
action yes we're looking at the state's
attorney it is not on the level from
beginning to end and there needs to be a
level of accountability throughout the
system and this sends an unambiguous
message that there is no accountability
and that is wrong okay so Rahm Emanuel
fighting that and of course attacking
Jesse small that's to saying you know
how dare he do this which of course is
exactly right here is the mayor of
Chicago saying this is just absurd mr.
Smolin is still saying that he is
innocent still running down the Chicago
Police Department how dare him how dare
you
after everybody saw and I want to remind
you this is not the superintendent's
word against his
the grand jury a sliver of the evidence
and they came to a conclusion as did the
state's attorney's office and even after
this whitewash stare still no sense of
ownership of what he's done he says that
in fact he is the wrong in this case
okay so Rahm Emmanuel fighting that over
this he's not the only one fighting mad
over this we'll see in a second that
there are other high-ranking officials
who are very upset over this the media
however we're really saying what about
the whole thing pretty amazing
so here's Chicago PD Superintendent
Eddie Johnson he's watched his
department get dragged through the mud
by Jesse Smollett Jesse Smollett
suggesting that the lack of charges
brought against these phantom white men
who attacked him that that was the fault
of the racist CPD here's the Chicago PD
superintendent saying listen this is a
hoax it's obvious it was a hoax the
guy's guilty at the end of the day
this mr. Smollett who committed this
this this this hopes period if he wanted
to clear his name the way to do that was
in a court of law so that everyone could
see the evidence okay well you know that
last point is not a great one because
obviously you're gonna take whatever
deal is put in front of you with that
said Eddie Johnson has every right to be
livid about all of this
now what's hilarious is to watch as
Democrats and the media pretend that
they don't know what happened here
Democrats and the media but I repeat
myself continue to pretend that this is
all just a giant mystery guys it's just
like Oh Jay you know like who was the
real killer anyway and I'm really
looking forward to the buddy cop comedy
where Jesse and OJ go looking for the
real killer and the real hate crime
perpetrators across America and turns
out it was in the mirror the whole time
you know the adventure was really the
journey at the end of that adventure the
real truth is at least I made friends
that'll be the end of that that buddy
cop comedy in any case here's brian
Stelter doing yeoman's work as the
ombudsman of legal and and journalistic
ethics over at CNN brian Stelter saying
you know we may never know what happened
I mean it's a mystery a mystery wrapped
in an enigma we may never know you know
despite the fact that we have like a
sign check and we have tip and these
guys buying all the goods and we have
the cell phone records and we have all
sorts of evidence and we have their
testimony look Brett brian Stelter says
it we just don't know
guys we just we have to withhold
judgment but I do think we will see
Smollett get back to work because the
the narrative is once again changed from
victim you know to villain back to
victim it's been very confusing as as
Ryan was saying people don't know what
to believe and we may never really know
what happened on the street that night
in Chicago but for his fans for his
friends this is a triumphant moment that
he can now get back to what he wants to
do which is work oh that's exactly what
he wants to do I mean aside from faking
racial hoaxes for publicity that's
really what he wants to do is work after
all I mean he wants to get back to
making $100,000 per episode the reports
were according to Eddie Johnson you'll
recall that Jesse Smollett did all of
this to increase his pay rate because it
wasn't enough to make millions of
dollars in a supporting part on a
network TV show now he needed to
increase it but Brian
brian Stelter showing the curiosity of a
feeble-minded chameleon there and is
that well I mean I guess the tongue will
not we'll never know what happened on
that street guys I mean it's just
mysteries mysteries what do we do about
this Kamala Harris said the same thing
the senator from California who declared
this a modern day lynching the same day
it happened now she's just confused
which is weird I was told that she was
once a prosecutor and that she had a
legal mind and that she can spot crime a
mile away with her eagle eye but now
Jessie Smollett comes along it's like
well I don't know it's also puzzling and
can I just can't i can't suss this one
out what do you think about what
happened to Jesse Smollett in Chicago
today to be perfectly honest with you
wolf I'm completely confused I don't
understand I don't know I don't know the
underlying evidence I haven't you know
there's a sealed document obviously I
don't know I'm at a loss I think we're
gonna have to leave it up to the
judgment of the the prosecutor I think
we should leave it up to the judgment of
the police chief and the mayor of course
to give us some better sense of what's
going on I don't know I mean I just
don't know it's such a mystery like the
day that had happened and he reported
this she called it a modern day lynching
linking it to you know racial lynchings
of the past but now we know exactly what
happened and it's I'm confused guys I
mean I don't know I'm it's just how am I
supposed to come to a conclusion when I
have every single bit of evidence now
what was hilarious is wolf blitzer on CN
n tried this with Rahm Emanuel and Rahm
Emanuel essentially curb stomp them and
here was the full picture painted by the
evidence perhaps not as compelling as
what was presented to the grounds you're
telling enough it was compelling enough
what do you say the evidence presented
to the grand juries what brought the
charge is it the police did a good job
and the evidence holds up and he
actually did commit the hoax they're
saying ten thousand dollars and two days
of community service is good enough and
I don't believe not only is it not good
enough especially when he's walking
around thinking that he is actually
innocent not guilty and B he's innocent
not on not only legally and a criminal
justice sense he is also guilty in my
view of a moral crime which is to use
the hate crimes to advance his
career for selfish reasons rom immanuel
the voice of reason what in the world is
going on guys I don't even know Donald
Trump's fever dream in which we are all
just living continues the Cook County
attorney came out and said yeah we know
Jesse's guilty like we're not pretending
that he's innocent here this was maggots
the the the second literally named
maggots the the second in command over
at the state's attorney's office he was
asked about this he's like it was you
know it wasn't really like we let him
off the hook it's an alternative
disposition guys it's an alternative
disposition this was not an exoneration
to say that he was exonerated by us or
anyone else is is not true I called an
alternative disposition in that he
agreed to do community service he agreed
to forfeit his bail to the remainder of
his bond to the city of Chicago and in
in return for him doing those things we
agreed to dismiss the indictment okay so
yeah and then he says so he was a so is
he innocent right and he's like no not
not not really actually just dropping
the charges vindicate him no does it
exonerate him no do you believe that he
is innocent I do not believe he's
innocent
so you believe he's guilty yes so why
drop the charges based on all the facts
and circumstances based on his lack of
criminal background I mean we defer or
do alternative prosecution's in the last
two years we've done 5,700 other felony
cases you mean Chicago is super corrupt
no no my favorite part of this is
smollett's attorney who is gamely trying
to play this thing out
Milan's attorney goes on with Don Lemon
who said that he wanted justice Millette
story to be true who said that he was
texting with jussie Smollett when all of
this is happening and some alleged
attorney is now relegated to having to
explain why to nigerian-born brothers
who were friends with Jesse Smollett
committed a hate crime I am not kidding
you this is the this is the news story
her small its attorney doing this
routine I'm not the prosecutor in the
case I have no idea what they're doing
as in any criminal matter people operate
behind the scenes that's how it should
be all I do know is that jesse was
attacked that night that it was someone
else who called the police and that
things went downhill from there I have
no idea why or what
the motive would be behind a situation
like this we don't know there's just no
it doesn't make sense that Jesse has to
be the one to come up with an answer to
why someone attacked him um yeah it does
since he is the one who made the whole
thing up so there is that okay meanwhile
in other in other hilarious news I mean
that this new cycle is just bizarro
world and in hilarious in many ways so
the Democrats have been claiming for a
long time people are dying we need the
green New Deal it's been featured on the
cover of Time magazine it's been
featured by The Washington Post we've
heard the intelligentsia sound off on a
OC so fresh so face so much incredible
freshness as well as faceless and her
green New Deal which is the most
important piece of legislation since
World War two we are in a battle with
the Sun and we are gonna win it and if
it costs us 93 trillion dollars over the
next ten years ie $65,000 per American
family every year from now until doom
well then we're gonna do it because
otherwise in 12 years heads were dead in
a dozen years that's right you're
plotting your kids are plotting your
grandparents are plotting we're gonna
dig them up they're gonna plots again
that's how all this is gonna work hey OC
yesterday was like you know what guys
like well like people while they're
dying like well this is not an elitist
issue this is a quality-of-life issue
you want to tell people that their
concern and their desire for clean air
and clean water is elitist people are
dying they are dying and the response
across the other side of the aisle is to
introduce an amendment five minutes
before a hearing in a markup this is
serious this should not be a partisan
issue
this is serious people are dying guys we
need a vote on the way no no no no no
sorry sorry let me rephrase
we need a debate about it I'm gonna
introduce this bill it is so important
we're gonna kill the farting cows and
get rid of airplanes we're gonna wreck
every building a retrofit every building
in the United States we're gonna get rid
of cars I mean guys it's gonna be the
best we're gonna invent unicorns that
float on their own flatulence but their
flatulence has no carbon emissions none
no methane methane free flatulence from
unicorns that's all this is
work the Democrats proposal this right
ed markey does it and we are told by
Cory Booker very seriously this is the
most important moment of our lives and
we are told by Kamala Harris that this
is so important and we're told by
Elizabeth Warren this is so Elizabeth
Warren says that this green New Deal is
like the moon landing which she should
know since she recently was on the moon
it's where she gets most of her ideas
here's Elizabeth Warren yesterday saying
that the green New Deal is so important
it's just like when we landed on the
moon except for not at all like that
President Kennedy challenged our nation
to lead the space race and less than
seven years later Neil Armstrong set
foot on the moon
the impossible had become a reality and
America had led the way it's time not
only to challenge our country to tackle
climate change head-on but also to lead
the world in doing so if we do not lead
then others will if we don't lead others
will and if others do we're all gonna
die everybody's gonna die death all
around so Mitch McConnell looks at the
green new deal he's like you know what
you're right it's super important I see
now how important it is because you guys
keep jabbering about it incessantly so
you don't we should do there's probably
vote on it let's have a vote let's see
if we can finally move forward on the
most pressing issue of our age it is
deeply important we must move forward on
this cocaine Mitch bringing it to the
floor for a vote and then Senator Mike
Lee who is low-key extremely funny so
Senator Mike Lee of Utah friend to the
program and personal friend about it
he's really really one of the things
about Mike Lee is the dude he's like Bob
Newhart he said he's really funny but
it's all with the straight face so Mike
Lee did a speech on the floor of the
United States Senate mocking the living
daylights out of the green new deal
mainly by using memes which was just
great so my favorite is he brought out a
painting of Ronald Reagan riding of a
Lhasa Raptor while firing a machine gun
and he explained what this had to do
with the green New Deal after reading
the green New Deal I'm mostly afraid of
not being able to get through this
speech with a straight face for mr.
president I rise today
to consider the green new deal with the
seriousness it deserves this is of
course a picture of former President
Ronald Reagan naturally firing a machine
gun while riding on the back of a
dinosaur you'll notice a couple of
important features here first of all the
rocket launcher strapped to President
Reagan's back and then the stirring
unmistakable patriotism of the
Velociraptor holding up a tattered
American flag a symbol of all it means
to be an American this image has as much
to do with overcoming communism in the
20th century as the green New Deal has
to do with overcoming climate change in
the 21st he did this whole thing about
how the only way under the green new
deal to get from Hawaii to the mainland
was to swim like Aquaman they put like a
picture of Aquaman riding a dolphin it
was great it was great so the media did
with the media - the media pretended
that they don't understand what a joke
is when somebody on the right does
something funny the media's first
response is what is joke why how funny
what what do funny mean and then they
then they run headlines like Mike Lee
makes bizarre criticism of green New
Deal showing Reagan on velociraptors
like no it's a joke idiot and we all
know you're lying we all know you get
the joke but you're gonna pretend to
play it straight zits he's so weird man
I mean he used the meme but a Aussie
she's super cool when she uses memes and
says like a lot and also has an instant
pot I know god it's amazing so here's
the best part of this so it comes up for
the vote all 53 Republicans vote no on
the stupid green New Deal and for
Democrats meaning three Democrats in
independent angus King of Maine they
also vote no that would be Kyrsten
Sinema of arizona voting no and suck
Jonesville a Bama voting no an intro
Manchin of West Virginia voting no all
because they are in purple states or red
states and they are afraid of losing
their seats if they vote for this
dumbass plan okay then we get to the
actual Democrats including no less than
six different Democratic senators voting
on this thing so how did they vote did
any of them vote in favor of bringing
the most important piece of legislation
of our time to the floor did any of them
in favor of this world-changing
world-beating proposal to end every
single Democrat voted present everyone
they didn't wanna be on record behind
this thing
so they voted president a present which
means basically no right they voted
present and then they proclaimed that
the real bad actor here obviously I mean
come on the real bad actor clearly is
Mitch McConnell so it's not us for
proposing this dumb stupid deal that
nobody wants and looks terrible and is
pointless and doesn't achieve what it
seeks to achieve and pledges to destroy
the American economy and wreck the
future of the United States that's not
on us it's time Mitch McConnell for
bringing it up to a vote so Democrats
bring this thing up and then they're
like this is the most important thing
we've ever done
McConnell's like good let's vote on it
no no you drinky tricky mcconnell haha
now you're not gonna catch us in the
voting on it and then they just run away
like King Arthur and Monty Python and
the Holy Grail just run away guys run
away okay in a second we're going to get
to the Democratic response to the vote
because it's really really funny but
first let me remind you that you should
go subscribe over at daily wire comm
when you do for $9.99 a month you get
the rest of this show live you get the
two additional hours of the show every
day I mean what more can we do for you
I'll tell you what more we can do for
you people we can also have a Sunday
special available on Saturday with extra
material behind the paywall this week's
Sunday special features the inimitable
extraordinarily Dowler Matt Walsh of The
Daily wire it's matt walsh tune in this
week to the ben shapiro sunday special
we're gonna be talking about a lot of
important issues heaven and hell the
catholic church what's going on with
society yoga Game of Thrones a lot of
interesting subjects we'll see you this
week spoiler alert you doesn't like yoga
so go check that out right now for $99 a
year you get all of those things Plus
this the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr cast your eyes upon it and be
enlivened enraptured by its joy look at
it the leftist here is hot or cold
tumblr you could hold this in your very
hand if only if only you weren't so
stingy so go check it out over at Taylor
also what more can we get I'll tell you
what more we can give you we can give
you this coffeemaker that also makes
julienne fries you can join us tomorrow
at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific for the
latest episode of daily wire backstage
daily where God can
Jeremie boring me Andrew Klavan the
horrible Michael Knowles and this week's
special guest Matt Walsh will be here to
cover the neverending insanity of
today's political climate as always only
daily wire subscribers get to ask the
questions and speak with sassy Alisha so
make sure to subscribe today pregnancy
has made Alisha incredibly sassy I can
say that because she's like my sister
which means I can make fun of her just
like I make fun of my own sisters go
check it all out over at daily wire.com
$99 a year gets you the annual
subscription also go over to YouTube
iTunes leave us a review follow us we
always appreciate it we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the United States
[Music]
so the Democrats are fighting fighting
mad and Mitch McConnell and Mike Lee for
mocking their beautiful wonderful
program basically the Democrats brought
home a stripper to mom and mom was like
yeah this is a bad idea like I love her
though she's the best it moms like some
fun money you marry her and they'd have
a joint bank account they're like nah ha
ha ha ha ha ha we're not gonna do that
we're not stupid enough for that so it
was really funny to watch the Democrats
yesterday trying to trying to back out
of this thing as slowly as humanly
possible so Richard Blumenthal the the
foolish senator from Connecticut he says
no you know what you know what we'll
vote at present I mean we're not gonna
vote YES on it cuz that would be real
dumb we're gonna vote present you have
signed on to senator Marquis green new
deal
how will you be voting today I support
the green new deal we may be voting
present simply as a kind of protest
against the McConnell stunt here it
really is
in a way a real disservice to the
legislative process to put on the floor
a proposal that he knows the president
won't sign that is done just to drive a
wedge between different parts of our
Democratic colleague I was informed this
was the most popular necessary plan in
the history of the Republic that's what
I was told I was told a oh she was
uniquely singular figure in Democratic
Party politics this thing was so amazing
it was a maze balls it was flaming
amazeballs it was just incredible in
every possible way and now the Democrats
are like I can't he want us to vote on
it I mean what a jerk
want us to vote on our own proposal we
got to have hearings so what here's what
McConnell should do next you should be
like you know what you're right let's
have some hearings let's do this thing
I'm scheduling a bunch of hearings for
the financial impact of the green New
Deal and I want to hear from you people
about why you think it's necessary to
destroy every standing building in the
United States or retrofit it I'd like to
hear about the slaughter the mass
slaughter of dying cows it's the Silence
of the cows out there so let's hear
about it
Kirsten Gillibrand who is legitimately
the worst and she's just she says it
she's really funny in the sense that
she's so obvious about everything that
she does as I've said before she's an
age reversed Hillary Clinton she she has
all of the charisma of speedbump she has
all of the mental agility of gumbie it's
pretty it's pretty astonishing so
Kirsten Gillibrand she tweeted out you
know what guys we got to stop playing
games stop playing games that's my job
to play games she tweeted up here's a
radical idea instead of a game of
political pinata with our planets future
let's have a real debate about the great
New Deal
and I haven't even better idea instead
of having a real debate let's just vote
on it she says we're talking about
infrastructure job creation and clean
air and water and if Republicans don't
support that they should explain why if
you don't support it you should explain
why Kirsten Gillibrand you voted present
I was informed we will all die in the
next dozen years if Democrats didn't
vote for this thing and you didn't vote
for it the children are asking you madam
senator why you wouldn't protect their
future the children so AOC was quite
humiliated by all of this she was very
sad about all of this she says
Republicans just want to play games like
yeah it's terrible we have thousands of
people whose lives are at risk there are
towns in Iowa that went completely
underwater and they want to play oh they
just want to play games with that I mean
just oh man and then my favorite is that
she tweeted this out she tweeted out
after everybody voted president and not
a single senator voted for her crappy
plan including Ed Markey who sponsored
her crappy plan she tweeted out because
I encouraged them to vote present along
with others McConnell tried to rush the
green New Deal straight to the floor
without a hearing
the real question we should be asking
why does the Senate GOP refuse to hold
any major hearings on climate change so
first of all they should and I hope that
Mitch McConnell takes her up on that
second of all this is basically her
saying I'm not owned I'm not owned as
she slowly shrinks and transforms into a
corn cob Mitch McConnell's office
tweeted out a picture of aoc her face
slowly transforming into a corn cob and
by the caption i'm not owned i'm not
owned ah glorious glorious day really
really funny stuff again guys you don't
like your own idea don't put it forward
if it wasn't ready for primetime maybe
you shouldn't have elevated it and yet
you decided that a OC was going to be
the spokesperson for your dumb ideas and
she goes forth and then you just sawed
off that branch right behind her and
there she is standing in midair saying I
told all the Senators to vote president
guys that was my idea so question Chuck
Schumer question Kristin Gillibrand
question Elizabeth Warren question cory
booker question amy klobuchar question
Kamala Harris question to every Senate
Democrat who's running for president
plus the Senate budget Minority Leader
is it true that aoc a first-term
congresswoman with the IQ of a kumquat
is now giving you orders as to how you
should vote on bills is that true and if
so why should you be President of the
United States or Senate Minority Leader
if this person who can mix a perfect Tom
Collins but not write a bill if this
person is considered the intellectual
heavyweight in your party why should we
give you any credence at all was she
like
really want to know and if there were a
journalist in Washington DC alive today
I know I apparently the failure of the
passage of the green New Deal has killed
all the journalists because none of them
will ask any of the Democratic senators
whether aoc told them to vote President
Xi says they did so I want to know are
the Democratic senators taking their
orders from this numbskull are they
taking their orders from this person I'm
sorry she's in she's ignorant okay it is
not my fault she's ignorant it is your
fault that she's ignorant you elected
her and then you made her into a star
and now you're taking orders from her it
is she who single-handedly sunk the
entire green New Deal roll out with her
dumb fact of frequently asked questions
that we read word for word on air when
it came out it was so stupid so this
one's on you it ain't on me
okay meanwhile speaking of the fresh
faces of the Democratic Congress so
incredibly fresh as well as incredibly
face I mean just freshness and faceless
beyond imagination I will point out that
Rasheeda Talib and Ilhan Omar continued
to be rabid anti-semite so that's
exciting
Ohan Omar's chief of staff or her
communications director tweeted
something out today
what did she tweet out she tweeted he
tweeted out rather he tweeted out and
I'm reading this directly the his name
is Jeremy Slevin he has a past working
for I kid you not
keith ellison who is not a friend to the
Jews as well as Louis Farrakhan really
not a friend to the Jews he tweeted out
Jeremy Slevin quote anti-semitism is a
right-wing force anti-semitism is a
right-wing force anti-semitism right
wait for us I said because the
right-wing force he just tweeted that
out like 20 times because nothing is
quite as convincing as when a person
just repeats a sentence over and over to
me I know it works with my kids when my
son just stands there and shouts at me
that he wants a cookie I'm so much more
likely to give him a cookie or
alternatively I never give him a cookie
when he does that because he's just
proving himself to be a small crazy
person he's to Jeremy's Levin is
presumably not to and yeah he keeps
repeating that anti-semitism is a
right-wing force
he works for illa Han Omar who is an
open anti-semite Johan Omar has not
hidden the ball here and speaking of
anti-semites in Congress Rasheeda Talib
who is set who has used the dual loyalty
smear her
self on on every Israel supporter and
Jews particularly if she has a person
who she specifically invited to her
inauguration and that person was
protesting APEC and stood outside of
AIPAC and shouted that the Jews are the
real Nazis that guy was invited to
Rasheeda Talib 's inaugurations her
swearing-in here he was outside the
rally shouting that the that the Jews
were actually just Nazis okay it really
is astonishing yet to pretend that a
strong strain of anti-semitism does not
run inside the Muslim community is to is
to pretend away the truth okay the fact
is there is a strong strain on the
anti-semitism that runs in the Muslim
community that does not mean that
everyone who is Muslim is an anti-semite
of course it does not mean that every
Muslim hates Jews it does mean that
there is a strong strain of
anti-semitism that is present in a lot
of Muslim communities around the world
and that is mainstream in a lot of
circles which is why Rashida Talib can
host an anti-semite like this guy at her
inauguration she's an anti-semite
Ilhan Omar is an anti-semite you wonder
how strong this strain is I mean it's
it's strong enough that it aimed at an
actual and natural memorial honoring the
slain in Christchurch the leader of a
mosque got up I mean this is a major
mosque in New Zealand and blamed Mossad
and the Jews for the shooting in
Christchurch
[Music]
and then there's a guy shouting it's the
truth Israel's behind this he says this
at a rally of hundreds and hundreds of
people Mossad of course is the
intelligent Foreign Intelligence Agency
of Israel is essentially the CIA of
Israel that was Achmed bomb Zhi the
chairman from the amount Roscoe mas
treaty
Omar so good times over there that's
that's just wonderful and covering for
all of this anti-semitism is of course
the Huffington Post which has as its
lead today dual loyalty is a slur that
targets Muslims so lest you be unless
you be thinking that Ilhan Omar accusing
Jews of dual loyalty and his real
supporters of dual loyalty is
anti-semitic the real to a loyalty slur
is targeted at Ilhan Omar three actually
actually the real dual loyalty slur is
targeted at rashida to leave now I've
never suggested that Rashida Talib has
dual loyalty I've never suggested a ohan
Omar has dual loyalty I have suggested
that there are anti-semites and that's
because they are and the progressive
wing of the Democratic Party that
continues to lend credence to these
people is disgracing itself in
incredibly epic ways the fact that
Democratic Party continues to promote
these quote-unquote fresh faces is
absolutely stunning and telling and it
turns out that anti-semitism is not a
right-wing phenomenon anti-semitism
exists in virtually every political
movement and where it is most virulent
the political movement is most dangerous
where it is most virulent in today's
world is not inside the Conservative
Party in the United States it's not
inside the Republican Party this is
perfectly obvious from every poll done
it is perfectly obvious from the
behavior of Republican Congress people
it is perfectly obvious from behavior of
President Trump who by the way is
extraordinarily Philo Semitic and
happens to be the best friend of Israel
who has ever sat in the White House and
it is not close the repository of
anti-semitism in the modern world in
politics is largely on the political
left those are the people who are
covering for Muslim anti-semitism in the
Middle East those are the people who are
making excuses for Hamas today as Hamas
continues to fire rockets into southern
Israel at civilian areas these are the
people who continue to claim that Israel
is the bad actor in a conflict in which
Israel simply argues for its own right
to exist these are the same people who
are claiming that attacks on synagogues
are really just anti-zionism
not anti-semitism
it is the it is the political left that
has made room for anti-semitism in its
main streams why Jeremy Corbyn is the
head of the Labour Party in Britain and
it's why AOC and Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib are considered the leading lights
of the Democratic Party and it's the old
fashioned Democrats who still suggest
that Israel is important it's Nancy
Pelosi and Stinney hora you know people
over the age of 65 it's those old
fashioned Democrats who still look at
Israel and see a democratic free country
who still look at Jews and say yeah
those are fellow Americans those people
are the old guard in the Democratic
Party which is the reason why so many of
the Democratic presidential candidates
decided to skip a pack this year Kamala
Harris with all the with all the
intestinal fortitude of an empty vessel
met secretly met quietly with people
from AIPAC but she wouldn't go to AIPAC
because she was tissues afraid of
ticking off for progressive base
Ilhan Omar's comms person tweeting out
anti-semitism as a right-wing phenomenon
your boss is in anti-semitism is an
anti-semite dude and from all indicators
at your your past employment you seem
pretty comfortable with all of that okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today there is a good movie from
Steve McQueen not the guy from Bullitt
the director of 12 years of slave the
movie is called widows now the movie is
kind of weird because it's actually like
three movies in one and it doesn't hold
together completely but it's got some
really interesting things about it so
the the most interesting thing about
this movie is the way that a portray
Chicago is basically just the center of
American corruption which of course as
we've seen today
it absolutely is Colin Farrell is
running for City Alderman he's running
against a black guy who happens to be a
former gangster and still is into you
know basically all sorts of organized
crime and that is one story and that
intersects with a a heist part of the
film which is really about the widows of
these guys deciding to hold the robbery
and then there is an interpersonal drama
between Liam Neeson who is white and I'm
violet violet Davis is that the name of
the actress I can't remember the name of
the actress she's really good Viola
Davis thank you um and she is and she is
his wife and they have a kid and the kid
is shot during a traffic stop by the
police so there's a little bit of an
interpersonal drama there it's really
three movies in one which means that
it's too packed it's
much it's too many storylines it could
have been more straightforward ACOTA
lost half an hour but all the political
commentary about the city of Chicago is
pretty spot-on here's a little bit of
the preview you have no idea do you what
did you choose not to know
[Music]
your husband stole two million dollars
for me
[Music]
this is about my life
because it's about my life now becomes
about yours movies really well shot and
and it's it's good it's it's it's a
pretty interesting movie it has a stupid
twist about 35 minutes from the M but it
didn't get past that the movie is is at
least very interesting Elizabeth de
Becky's a revelation she is a terrific
actress she's also eight feet tall and
it really makes her stand out in this
film she's towers over everybody you'll
also remember her from guardians of the
galaxy to I believe where she plays one
of the the aliens and she's she's
terrific
she really connect she's in the new
Chris Nolan movie that's all I care
about by the way people is I was asked
on the conversation what movies I was
looking forward to and the answer is
anything Chris Nolan makes ever so I
don't even know what his movie is in
2020 it's supposed to be an action flick
and the cast is supposed to be just
stellar it's like a top-line cast it's
Robert Pattinson and I'm trying member
who else in the guy from black clansmen
and they're a bunch of really good
actors in it so looking forward to that
okay time for some things that I hate
all right so let's begin with cardi B so
cardi B is a rapper she's a rap star and
every so often she issues a little rant
about how she doesn't want the
government taking her money and that's
amusing but she is not exactly a model
citizen nor has she ever proclaimed to
be one well now there's a piece of tape
that came out from about three years ago
in which she discusses the fact that she
used to seduce men back to her apartment
or their apartment and then she would
drug them and robbed them right this is
what she legitimately says this out loud
and then she issued kind of a half-assed
apology that's not really quite an
apology
[Music]
difficult to hear exactly what she's
saying them were just a lot of cursing
and a lot of yelling but she says that
when she was a stripper she would drug
and rob men she'd bring them back to her
apartment and then she's and then she
she issued a statement saying this so
I'm seeing on social media that alive I
did three years ago has popped back up
alive where I talked about things I had
to do in my past right or wrong that I
felt I needed to do to make a living
that is not a good excuse drugging and
robbing people that is a crime gang and
in America you do not actually need to
drug and rob people in order to make a
living and if you feel that you needed
to do that to make a living that is
still called a crime says I never
claimed to be perfect or come from a
perfect world with a perfect past I
always speak my truth I always own my
bleep I'm a part of a hip-hop culture
where you can talk about where you come
from about the wrong things you had to
do to get where you are there are
rappers that glorify murder violence
drugs and robbing crimes they feel they
had to do to survive
she's right about this it is one of my
main critiques of rap culture which is
that you glorify all this crap and
that's bad
she says crimes they feel they had to do
to survive I never glorified the things
I brought up in that live I never even
put those things in my music because I'm
not proud of it and I feel a
responsibility not to glorify it I made
the choices that I did at the time
because I had very limited options again
drugging and robbing men not an option
says I was blessed to have been able to
rise from that but so many women have
not so does she know of any of the other
women who are drugging and robbing men
cuz that seems kind of bad says whether
or not they were poor choices at the
time I did what I had to do to survive
she keeps saying that as though we don't
have welfare programs in the United
States or charitable programs or the
United States or as though she wasn't
working a job as a stripper at the time
or as though she couldn't get a job as a
waitress or anything I guess the job
shows a choice between starvation and
drugging and robbing men that was the
choice pretty sure that's not true
because the men I spoke about in my life
were men that I dated that I was
involved with men that were conscious
willing and aware you're gonna have to
explain to me hey drugged and robbed
somebody and they were conscious willing
and aware that's pretty weird I mean
like it seems to me that if you drug
somebody they are by necessity not
conscious willing and aware just just me
and biological reality and facts over
here but you know she was there cuz I
have a past that I can't change we all
do okay so that's what
he has to say about this she will be
exonerated involved this will pretend
that it's not a big deal that she just
admitted to openly committing a series
of crimes now is there evidence of this
should she I mean again there's no
victim that has come forward she should
not be prosecuted for crimes that cannot
be proved but the the willingness of
people to overlook stuff like this
because she happens to be what imagine
if it had been a man if it were our
Kelly he said you know what back in my
past you know that I used to do I used
to go out to the street and then I would
convince women to come back to my
apartment then I would drug and I would
rape them and then I would take their
money it's what I had to do survive man
what I had to do to survive you'd all be
like uh what now you should go to jail
but she says this feminism would suggest
that if men and women are truly equal we
should be pretty appalled by all of us
now there's something that we are
appalled by today something deep and
important that we are all appalled by
today this comes courtesy of the San
Francisco Chronicle here is the name and
the Washington Post here's the name of
the article teen boys rated their female
classmates based on looks the girls
fought back boom whammo this from
Bethesda Maryland yes mean bepah honey
had just walked into her third period
health class when her friend asked if
she had seen the list there's a list of
the girls names her friend Nikki Schmidt
a fellow senior at Bethesda Chevy Chase
high school in Maryland said and were
ranked babba Hani didn't want to see the
list or know whether she was on it she'd
spent the past four years recovering
from an eating disorder working hard to
avoid comparing herself with others she
said but by her sixth period class on
that Monday earlier this month a text
message appeared on her phone with a
screenshot of the list typed out on the
iPhones note app and included the names
of 18 girls at this high school ranked
and rated on the basis of their looks
from five point five to nine point four
with decimal points to the hundredths
place there with a number beside it was
behind his name a group of male students
in their program created the list more
than a year ago but it resurfaced
earlier this month
through text messages and whispers
during class one male classmate seeing
the name of his good friend Nikki
Schmidt on the list told her about it
and within 24 hours dozens of girls had
heard about the list as well
lifts like this one had silently
circulated among teen boys for
generations and it has happened in more
recent years at Bethesda Chevy Chase
high school - the students said but it
was happening now
in the era of the me2 movement women had
been standing up to harassment in
workplaces and on college campuses and
the high school girls have been
witnessing this empowerment decided they
weren't gonna
the issues slide so a couple of quick
notes here men right women based on
books
yeah just hard to break it to ladies
this is called evolutionary biology men
have always males of species rape rape
females of species based on sexual
attractiveness you know that does not
mean that they should treat women based
on that level of sexual attractiveness
it doesn't mean that they should even
mate with women and marry women based
solely on the sexual attractiveness
scale in fact as I've argued 1,000 times
on the show people should date and marry
on the basis of values and not sexual
attraction alone although sexual
attraction is a component of a healthy
marriage but are we gonna pretend that
men don't actually see women sexually
are we gonna pretend that that teenage
boys don't look at teenage girls and
then rate their looks because that's
stupid now is it also stupid to compile
math lists like this yes it's immature
and it's dumb it's also something that
teenage boys do and treating it like
this is the height of crime worthy of a
piece in The Washington Post is pretty
astonishing it really is because is
there any evidence that the boys were
actually harassing the girls if so that
is an independent activity that should
be looked into
and the school should do something about
it but if a bunch of guys get together
and then create a secret list amongst
themselves where they rate the girls is
that wonderful no is that worthy of a
piece in The Washington Post for God's
sake no it is not so you're gonna ruin
these boys lives you know we're gonna
we're gonna now have the media try and
track down these boys presumably because
they had the temerity to basically
create an internal tinder app a group
tinder app that's that's it so this is a
high priority now again I don't I think
the girls have every right to be upset
about being treated like pieces of meat
but it's the overblown media coverage of
this that is truly astonishing and we're
all gonna and now we're all supposed to
pretend that teenage boys don't rape
teenage girls on the basis of looks by
the way teenage girls rate teenage boys
on the basis of looks as well I should
note but they say they felt violated
objectified by classmates they
considered friends note to teenage girls
teenage boys look at you as potential
sex object I will warn my daughter of
this I will warn every young woman of
this men it turns out like to look at
women and then potentially have sex with
them with consent this is this is
something that men like to do I hate to
break it to folks I mean I it's
uncomfortable
apparently they said that they said that
they they felt that there was power in
numbers as dozens of senior girls
decided to speak to the school
administration and to their male
classmates demanding not only
disciplinary action in response to the
list disciplinary action in response to
lists I'll tell you the solution to this
and that no one's gonna like you should
have separate boys and girls schools
when I was in high school we had a
separate boy school and a separate girls
school this is actually better for girls
forget about the boys it was much better
for girls because studies tend to show
that girls deliberately underperform in
classrooms in order to attract boys this
is what the social science tends to
suggest girls and boys are better off
separate in high school but we can't do
that that would be terrible
and repressive apparently it was the
last straw for us girls of this boys
will be boys culture said babba honey
were the generation that is going to
make a change so a group of girls
reported the list to an administrator
who encouraged the girl the girls not to
talk about it around school the next day
the girls learned that after an
investigation school officials decided
to discipline one male student with
in-school detention for a day and then
they had a struggle session because they
were unsatisfied with the disciplinary
action so they texted 15 girls and told
them to tell all of their friends to
show up at the school's main office the
next day during lunch to tell them we
feel unsafe in this environment and we
are tired of this toxicity I reiterate
this list was secret it's not like they
took the list printed it out and stuck
it on the wall that would be a form of
harassment but if I text one of my
friends when I'm in high school and I'm
like you know who's hot that girl and
then she gets ahold of that you know
what that is not that is not harassment
that is not harassment and that is not
toxicity that is called normal human
behavior if you got together and you
make a game out of it it makes it kind
of a jerk but it doesn't mean that you
should be disciplined by the school or
called out in the pages of the
Washington Post my goodness that fried
out an International Women's Day almost
all the students in the IB program about
80 students met in a large conference
room for what was supposed to be a 45
minute meeting instead the meeting
lasted two and a half hours several
girls delivered personal impassioned
speeches describing not only their
presence on the list but also their
previous experiences with sexual abuse
harassment and objectification again if
they were sexually abused or harassed
that is a different story that is
behavior that deserves punishment but
teenage boys texting each other about
who is hot in the class what
I legitimately can't get myself upset
enough that I think that these boys
should be targeted by the Washington
Post
over this is it good behavior again you
should for the 1000 time the segment you
should train your boys not to act like
this with regard to girls is this worthy
of me to coverage does this elevate to
the level that boys are supposed to be
punished in school for looking at a girl
and then raiding her looks is that
really what by the way you think boys
are gonna stop doing this because you
had a struggle session you think boys
know what a normal boy would do he would
say yeah it was kind of a jerky thing to
do to be part of that list I felt kind
of uncomfortable and objectifying it was
kind of gross but why are you lumping me
in with the guy who sexually abused you
because I didn't do that all I did was
say who I thought was hot or not hot or
not has been a thing in high school
since the dawn of high school how do not
has been a thing since forever it's
again not a wonderful part of human
nature but it is a part of human nature
the same people who suggest that you
can't teach it's amazing the same people
who suggest that you can't teach
abstinence-only before marriage will
suggest now that we can somehow beat it
out of boys to rape teenage girls based
on looks when they're in high school
good luck with that good luck with
obviously this should be top priority
for the Washington Post it this is it's
just it's over the top and it's
off-putting and it's not productive in
the end it doesn't make relations
between boys and girls better all it
really does is make boys more secretive
about their behavior and again leads the
media to believe that they're doing
something righteous when in fact they
are targeting kids who are legitimately
just being kids if girls had a similar
list about boys by the way you know what
the reaction would be nada
there'd be no reaction whatsoever nor
should there be nor really should there
be this is a question for the parents
this is this is a question for the pay
it's really not a question for the
school unless it was publicly posted in
the school then it becomes a question of
harassment already well we will be back
here for two more hours
later today and I look forward to seeing
you then in the meantime go pick up a
copy of my book the right side of
history go check it out right now i'm
ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone I'm Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know Chicago
has a reputation as a corrupt Democrat
machine town because it's a corrupt
Democrat machine town we saw that
yesterday in the justice Millette case
we saw it for eight years during the
Obama administration it's not a question
of Al Capone where Democrats gather it's
all Capone I'm Andrew Clavin that's on
the Andrew Clavin show